There is this big global industry
devoted to taking waste from
generally developed countries
and shipping it to poorer countries,
many of them in Southeast Asia.
Environmentalists have come up with a term
to describe this phenomenon,
and what they call it
is "waste colonialism."
The idea that rich countries
are dumping their problems,
literally in some cases,
onto poor countries
and letting poorer countries deal
with the waste created in the rich world.
I went to Thailand hoping
to see some of that process
and the problems it's causing first-hand.
You know, I've been looking
at the data and at numbers,
we've realized that a
tremendous amount of waste
are being, well I don't want
to use the word imported,
I want to use the word dumping,
dumped into our country.
I know before I got
involved in this research
what I thought about recycling
was wildly out of step
with the realities of the industry.
I cannot sleep here, right?
Oh, I see.
I come here and I open the house,
and inside the house has a
strong smell of the chemistry.
They can put up many, many plants.
They were planning for one,
but they told us that there
will be 13 more coming.
Thailand is not the global dumpster.
We are not an international bin, you know?
So if you don't have
anywhere to put your rubbish,
please don't put it in Thailand.
In 2021, Thailand received
about 158,000 tons
of imported plastic waste from overseas.
So that is a hell of a lot of material.
It obviously needs to be
processed. It needs to be recycled.
Not all of it can be.
And it may also cause externalities
like pollution, like noise, like fumes
that bother local residents.
So while we've all been
raised to think of recycling
as this kind of clean
and virtuous business,
this perfect circle,
actually there are big
problems with the process.
And so the factory's right here.
Where would the fumes
come from? From this side?
From this hole and this hole.
So for this story
one of the people I spoke to was a man
named Vinyou Jiaramankong.
Vinyou is an accountant.
He has a house in the Bangkok suburbs.
And a couple years ago
he found out that a
property next to his house,
which had previously been used
of a sort of storage yard,
was being turned into a recycling plant.
The whole area of this.
Was covered in smoke.
Yes, covered by smoke.
And that's why you have this big fan.
Yes.
So after this plant got going,
Vinyou noticed that there
were really noxious fumes
coming into his home.
You cannot breathe.
You have a headache.
Doctor said I need to
move my son out of here.
He told me that he was
having trouble breathing,
getting headaches. He was
experiencing skin irritation.
He started finding dead
pigeons on his front lawn,
which, as you can imagine,
is pretty alarming.
And it appears, based on
some scientists I spoke to
who looked at this issue,
that these were fumes
from hydrocarbon exposure.
That plastic was being melted down,
which of course creates fumes
that if they're not
properly filtered and vented
can be really damaging
to people and wildlife.
And so that's what Vinyou
was experiencing in his home.
So if this is killing pigeons,
it's pretty bad.
It's going to kill my family too.
So, I have to let it go.
And leave this house?
Yes, leave the house.
When I think of a recycling plant,
certainly, before I did this research,
you think of something
clean and inoffensive,
you know, part of this circular economy
that we're all told is
such a wonderful thing.
But the reality is a little messier.
Recycling plants can be quite
dirty and dangerous places.
They can throw off serious pollution,
chemicals that include things like dioxin
which had been associated
with increased risk of cancer.
So we're heading out of Bangkok now
to Chon Buri province,
and we're going to visit a community
where there's been a lot of opposition
to plastic recycling and
manufacturing facilities.
The company do not keep,
you know, follow the rule.
Follow the right thing.
Sometimes they just burn
the plastic, you know,
whenever they want.
They put this under the
ground, pollute the water.
You know, they run it all
the time making noises.
People cannot stand that.
Most of the people affected
by recycling plants,
and this is true all over the world,
tend to be poor, tend to be vulnerable,
people who don't have a lot of recourse
to the legal system or otherwise.
We organize three protests, actually.
Each one get bigger and bigger.
The last one was about
a year and a half ago
and we got together
right around 700 people
right in front of the factory, the plant.
We protest, we put up the sign,
but at the end, it's just
another activity that we did
but never get any response back.
There's a simple reason why
there is such a huge demand
for recycling globally,
and that is that we all consume
incredible amount of
plastic, in particular.
Plastic consumption has
skyrocketed all over the world.
But countries like the US,
like Japan, like the UK
don't have the domestic capacity
to recycle all that plastic.
In fact, they have nowhere near
the domestic capacity they would need.
So, the only way to deal with it,
if you don't want to just
throw it into landfill,
is to send it overseas, to stuff
it into shipping containers
and send it to poorer countries
where that infrastructure does exist.
So, that's what we've seen
over the last five or six
years in Southeast Asia
is a big increase in
long-haul recycling shipments
largely from the rich world.
We detected a container full
of so-called plastic scraps.
But, you know, you opened it
up, it's not scraps inside,
it's all plastic waste.
This is recently?
Yeah, a couple months ago.
Oh, really. OK.
So we kindly throw it back to the US.
I've asked our
pollution-control department
to coordinate very closely
with all the other agencies concerned,
and put, well, put our fist down on it.
Of course we cannot just say
we're going to stop from
100 to zero overnight.
It has to be a gradual change,
and, you know, there are differences
between plastic scraps and plastic waste.
Unfortunately, the plastic
waste are being disguised
as plastic scraps on paper.
And in the past, I think
some people have used it
as a loophole to bring
those waste into Thailand.
The Thai government
has for a few years now
been moving toward a ban on
foreign plastic waste import.
But as I learned from
the environment minister
and from others I've spoken to,
that's much easier said than done.
Recycling is a big industry.
There are, in Thailand,
Malaysia, Indonesia,
large and profitable companies
that depend on, among other things,
plastic waste imports from overseas.
And so, they've been
a source of opposition
to these measures.
Do you think the government
will really ban plastic
imports effectively?
Over the last several years,
Malaysia, Indonesia, Thailand,
those countries have cracked
down to varying extents
on waste imports.
And what's going to happen
next, I think it's very fair to
say, is these flows of waste
will find their ways to other countries,
and perhaps to countries
that are much poorer.
Myanmar is one that
gets talked about a lot.
There are countries in Africa
that are being talked about a lot
as potential destinations.
And these are places even
less able to cope with these
inflows than a Thailand
or an Indonesia is.